direction sotchi a dans le sud de la
russie sur les bords de la mer noire
dans cette station balnéaire le club
international de discussion valdaï vient
d'ouvrir ses portes pour quatre jours un
forum international qui vise à
rassembler des experts du monde entier
pour débattre de gouvernance et
d'économie à échelle mondiale le temps
at-elle enterré l'idée de consultations
avec la russie c'est en tout cas ce qu'a
souligné le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov les précisions
de notre correspondante à sotchi maëlys
d'estrées
les chefs de la diplomatie russe vient
en effet de répondre aux questions des
journalistes dans le cadre du club de
discussion valdaï cinglé lavrov n'a pas
manqué de commenter les relations entre
l'otan et la russie pour rappel à la
suite de la décision de l'alliance
atlantique de réduire les effectifs de
la mission russe auprès de l'otan à
partir du 1er novembre la russie a
annoncé hier qu'elle suspendait sa
mission auprès de l'organisation et
celle de l'alliance à moscou écoutez le
représentant de l'alliance ont enterré
les règles qui ont été mises au
fondement de ce qu'on sait et notamment
la nécessité d engendrer la consultation
dans les situations de crise pour ça
rien lavrov c'est à l'otan de faire le
premier pas pour normaliser ses
relations avec la russie car celle ci
n'est pas à l'origine de la dégradation
actuelle de ces relations ce qu'on a
réduit plusieurs fois un mot effectifs
dans les représentations pour entrer
pour pénétrer dans l'état major de
l'otan nos représentants sont obligés de
renvoyer une demande au préalable pour
l'accès au bâtiment il doit vous
suivre seulement le couloir qui leur
sont autorisés et bref
lorsqu'il s'agit des échanges
d'informations séquelles quasi
inexistant depuis longtemps des
déclarations fortes donc de la part du
chef de la diplomatie russe qui place la
balle dans le camp de l'alliance
atlantique